ramsay show you can be intentional about
your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney best-selling author and
host of the dr john deloney ever popular
podcast and youtube show is my co-host
today
so we'll talk about your mental health
uh your friends or your relatives mental
health
or your co-worker which is much more fun
go work what
already he starts with this all right so
um it's the problem with having a guy
with two phds on it's just intimidating
what can i say
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're going
to continue
our discussion of the largest
legal fraud in america today
in our third hour it's called time
shares
they put people in a room and won't let
them out for eight hours until they buy
and then they screw you and they screw
you and they screw you and they've made
billionaires out of the men that started
these things
and uh it's a crazy crazy
mixed up world and we're going to
continue to expose
the timeshare companies if you have been
messed over by a timeshare company which
means you
either have bought one or you haven't
[Laughter]
you can call and talk to kelly we want
to get you on in the third hour or you
can email me at
daveonair at ramsey solutions.com dave
on earth ramsey solutions.com put
timeshare scams
in the lineup maybe you used to work for
one of them
and you want to tell the truth about
what goes on in the inside
we've had a bunch of those over the
years we'll continue to get more of
those i'm gathering stories from
consumers
and people who have been screwed over by
this crazy out-of-control
multi-billion dollar business that
quietly continues to defraud
uh people and among them the elderly and
it's just they're preying on people and
it's got to stop so we're just
pounding them so third hour that's what
we're doing if you want to talk about it
we'd love to have you daveonair
ramseysolutions.com email us and let us
know we'll work you in
kevin is in dallas hey kevin welcome to
the ramsay show what's up
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
um
so so i'm uh i i'm
currently disabled and i was
applying for term life insurance
prior to me going on full full or long
term disability
and i was denied my application so
i went with a universal life insurance
policy
and i'm not really sure what to do
about whether i can find something
cheaper that would be term rather than
sticking with the universal life
what is the nature of your disability uh
i
it's it's called hereditary [ __ ]
paraplegia it's uh
basically it makes it hard really really
hard for me to walk
okay life insurance is going to be
difficult
of any kind uh and universal is no
harder to get than term
uh or no easier to get than term uh so
if you've already got a universal policy
for goodness sakes don't let that go
unless you found something cheaper and
got it in place in your hand
before you released it but you can go to
xander at xanderinsurance.com
get on the phone with them tell them
what you're facing and they will see if
they can find a company that will write
you
in the insurance world they call that
making a market
see if they can make a market for you
meaning find someone that will carry the
policy
in your situation permanent long-term
disability
is a statistical problem for the life
insurance
statistics and they generally will
they give you a real hard time with it
they just give you depending on what it
is
but most of it is very hard to get so
xander is
has got a way of doing it like nobody
i've ever met they do a great job of
really trying to serve you
make sure your specific thing so go to
xanderinsurance.com
so if you if if you find yourself in
that situation
and you're unable to get life insurance
at some point you're gonna have to
really reverse engineer out your life
and start saying
i may have to save more aggressively
than somebody else or i may have to
choose to not spend i mean you're going
to have to go with a plan b
right and there are some policies you
can get small policies they're super
expensive
they're guaranteed issue they issue them
to anybody no matter what
you just have to say i'm alive okay and
they'll issue them but that's probably
outrageous
they're like 20 times more expensive
right and you know it's usually a 10 or
20 000
policy too it's not a you can't get a
500 000 guaranteed issue
usually usually so again it depends on
the nature of what's going on and the
insurance world has changed a lot the
life insurance world because they're
they're doing a much better job of
not throwing the baby out with the bath
water on every category right
they'll drill down into the situation
and say okay in this situation i think
we can get this written
you know for instance if you if you just
had the word cancer anywhere around your
name
you were screwed you couldn't get life
insurance period yeah i mean no matter
10 years 20 years
you know your cancer's your heart your
heart you're out yeah you're done
and nowadays you know it it really does
depend on the type of cancer it depends
on what the treatment was
it depends on what stage it was it
depends on how long it's been
sin that you've been cancer free before
you try to get written and
you can get you know as a cancer
survivor you can get life insurance now
depending on you know the frequency what
it was and
the proximity and all that kind of stuff
christina is in kansas city hi christina
how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call i have
a question about
baptized my husband and i have been
married for almost 10 years and for the
first time we are searching for a new
church family
and for the last six months we have been
setting aside our tithe and a fund
but we're not sure what to do with the
money
we're wondering if we should just write
a big check when we find a new church
that we want to join
that'll be fine there's nothing wrong
with that you can find some local
churches in your area to spread it among
now if you want
um here's the thing um what we want to
do is we want to be obedient
to the scriptures those of us that are
people of faith with our generosity
the tithe is the baseline for our
generosity
but you can never stray away from why
why does god want us to be generous it's
good for you
because he wants to make you into a
generous person
and generous people are just more fun
they're happier
they're not depressed very often they
don't live in their own heads yeah
it's not all about you they live with
eyes the purpose is not every jot and
tittle meaning every little freaking
finite detail about the nuances of which
scripture or whatever and god is not
going
to bless that because you gave it to a
baptist instead of a church of christ or
whatever
there's none of that don't get caught up
in that uh
so it it so the point is you have set
this aside
you are going to be generous you're
going to give it to someone god's
smiling he's not wringing his hands
about where it lands
awesome because it's for you
does that make sense yes that's great
yeah
you're awesome i appreciate i you i
appreciate your heart
your character and your your your desire
to be true to your faith
and and i mean that's just very cool
that's a that's a person who's tethered
into their virtue
above and beyond experience right yeah
like i'm going to be this kind of person
whether i've got a a a category to send
this to right away this is who i am this
is who we are
and changing churches man it's just it's
like
like changing for somebody this is like
going through a divorce i mean it's just
because your socials tied in there
everything oh my gosh it's hard enough
that's tough you're going through a hard
thing right there kiddo
good for you that's inspiring man that's
very neat
honey it's for you giving yeah it's for
you you give
for you this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five if you're tired of feeling
stuck with your money like you'll never
get out of debt or save enough for the
future it does not have to be that way
you can
make progress with your money faster and
faster and faster with financial peace
university every dollar it's all part of
a ramsay plus
membership when you budget when you get
intentional with your money and you
start
learning the baby steps in detail with a
group of people
with ramsey plus it changes everything
you'll you will make progress and you'll
make it fast and you can start all this
including your new budget on every
dollar for free starting today with a
free trial of ramsey plus
text trial 233 789 that's
trial two three three seven eight nine
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds free
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more
use the promo code ramsey all right
today's question comes from
james in texas james writes my wife and
i pay our bills
based on our income good james i earn
more so we split the rent 70 30
go 50 50 on the electric bill and i pay
for cable
water and internet when we moved into a
new rental she asked if she could hold
off my god i'm just going to finish this
question
she asked if she could hold off paying
rent the first two months and i agreed
what a saint
the third month she was late with her
contribution and now she's going to be
late again this month i ask her to
manage her paycheck and other debts so
that she uses the second check of the
month to save for rent and electricity
to avoid being late and she got
mad it was like she's a little late to
the mad party i'm already there
was i wrong anywhere yeah everywhere
yeah you were just wrong before the
whole thing started 100 percent james
everyone
both are going to smack you around are
you ready i was helping her manage her
pay what a what a saint
more responsibly because paying things
late is a bad habit to break you know
what else is a bad habit
being an idiot james what are you doing
it's like he's living with a with a
co-worker
right like they're co-running a business
i don't know man listen dude this is
your wife
you remember the part richer for poorer
in sickness and in health so when you're
laying in the bed with the flu
i hope she doesn't give you as much crap
about making you some chicken soup
because you're sick as you are about
making her be a grown-up and manager
many by herself oh my god dude
really come on man so um yeah you
here's here's the thing son you guys
need to put your money together together
you work on it together you make
decisions
and together we manage our money for the
good of our family this is not your
roommate
the old marriage vows say unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge if you
wanted a roommate you shouldn't have
gotten
married and if you want to divide up
your life
into mine and yours and you owe me this
and that and i'll let you borrow this
from it
man just listen to that language that's
not a marriage
it's not a marriage that's a business
arrangement it's not even a good
friendship no it's not even buddies you
know what we all had this friend in
college that was like hey bro remember
wendy's you owe me 428 from
like three months ago yeah the mustard
that you used in the refrigerator door
that was mine
so you guys said it's like four dollars
dude i guess
everyone had that friend you know what i
learned about friendship in college i
got around some guys you know what the
fights were about who was covering the
check
like this is ours right that's just
knucklehead college buddies this isn't
a husband and a wife so james you all
have a pronoun issue
and that is y'all gotta sit in a room
and say what is yours and mine is
ours that's it right but yours and mine
is ours and we've got to do this thing
from there
you're not sanctioning irresponsibility
and she's not going to sanction you
being a control freak
out of control arrogant jerk yes
nobody wants i had enough adjectives in
there
and i kind of want to hug you man
because you know what i read this and
after you called him an idiot i know hey
that's that's a term of endearment for
me i know i i i want to hug him because
i think he's actually
trying to help and he's asking did i
screw this up
yeah yes you did you did but the the
that
question it's just it is astounding that
you could be that clueless though really
i know i wonder if that's even a real
question it's endearing
what's endearing there's that dumb yeah
when he's like hey did i mess this up
and everyone's like yes
of course it's relationally you get a
sub zero score here
no i'm gonna give him one one no because
he looked in the mirror and said
maybe it's maybe well now she's pissed
why did this woman wait this long to get
pissed i got to tell you
before the first sentence was over i
don't know billy woman at the ramsey
house would have been over it i'm just
saying i know but she's getting a free
ride here with
with this guy that this this romeo who's
paying for the internet
and she won the lottery i'm gonna give
you a little time off on that rent there
just listen i really like you
listen lady i'll get the internet in the
cable
because that's what men in texas do come
on james oklahoma city chelsea get us
out of this what's up
okay i'm a little nervous you're gonna
have to bear with me murder mystery
party
um i'm a stay-at-home mom and i'm trying
to
start a side hustle planning murder
mystery parties
but i'm like almost totally blind
and i'm not sure how upfront i should be
with my clients about that because i
don't want to be
disingenuous with them since it is a
visual
medium involved but at the same time
it's like it's my medical record
is that really their business i'm just
i'm not sure what to do because i don't
want to mislead people
flip shoes
you were going to a murder mystery place
would you care if the lady that put it
on
was blind not really unless
unless they couldn't do the job
can you plan awesome parties yes
and to the extent that your site
limitation would cause a mistake
you can go ahead and disclaim that on
the front end and people will give you a
lot of grace
okay that's a good idea i didn't think
about it but but you go look
but it's not a thing i got this yeah and
if i don't got it you can call me out on
it and we'll work it out together but i
got it i've done 26 of these or whatever
you've done and
there's no problems and so on but um
chelsea you throw that head back and go
yeah have at it
but just treat other people like you'd
want to be treated it solves
almost all your business ethics
questions
okay and yeah and by the way if i were
your customer that's exactly what i
would want
i don't care if i'm coming in there to
have a party and have fun
if the person conducting it is whatever
fill in the blank
i want an awesome party i don't care
until their whatever
affects my party right but if it affects
my party
uh and it's an and i need to have a
little bit of compassion with that
person or a little bit i'd like to have
had a heads up about that let's have a
conversation about it yeah
but so i don't get surprised because i
really you know like i'll tell you i'll
give you an example okay
i went to check into a hotel a while
back and uh we use only debit cards
and the stupid debit card had gotten an
algorithm hit for
i'd for id right for id theft
and i and then the people come back from
the uh
desk and they go well you're over your
limit
well honey my debit card don't have a
limit
okay this is freaking me it's got i can
do i can buy a car on my debit card if i
want to right
so but um it's late at night i'm tired
i'm exhausted
and i can't get a stupid hotel and i'm
pissed at my bank
i dial up my personal banker
and i was unhappy with her can you
imagine me doing that
yeah to which she says hey i'll get this
fixed in the morning
i'm at the visitation
for my dad's funeral can i work on it in
the morning
to which dave goes oh you're a butt to
dave
he says to himself gave the butt you
know you
so in other words if i had had that
piece of information i might have been a
little nicer to her right you follow me
yeah so just give me enough information
so that i can be kind
if i'm the customer if there's a mistake
that uh might be related to the
information
and chelsea i think what's gonna cause
you the most grief
is if you walk into business deals
self-conscious of something
if you think you're bringing um an
impairment to something
then you're gonna not sell yourself as
strongly go in with your head held high
you're gonna do a great job a community
with you is going to help you fill in
your gaps man you're going to go get it
the reason we know you're going to be
good is you bothered to ask the
questions awesome
you weren't like arrogant and throwing
around i love it entitlement stuff
i love it you just said hey how would
you how should you do this by the way
folks
if you're wondering how to act in
business always ask the question
how would i want to be treated if the
roles were reversed do unto others as
they would do unto you it solves almost
all your business ethics questions
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families
and we wanted to have more children and
we had also just started a real estate
company and needed to find health care
coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality host
of the dr john deloney show
you can hear it on youtube instagram
you can follow him anywhere great
podcasts
are carried and it's very popular and
growing very rapidly
if you'd like to ask him a question
about anxiety
about relationships about anything you
call today a triple eight
eight two five five two two five you can
email him at ask john
ramsey solutions dot com or you can
leave a voicemail and the team will get
you on the show
eight four four six nine three
thirty two ninety one also if you are a
victim of
a time share if you bought a timeshare
got ripped off you wanna tell the
timeshare
sales story the scam story on a
timeshare we're gonna be doing that in
the third hour
i need to hear from you email right now
so kelly can get you
scheduled for that show dave on air
at ramseysolutions.com by the way
whenever you hear this
if you want to share your timeshare
story we're going to be doing several
of these over the next several months
it's like my new hobby
i'm going to say i haven't seen you this
joyful dave oh i'm this is such
good radio it's also such the right
thing to do because it's the largest
legal fraud in america and when you get
to looking at them people behind the
scenes on this and how scummy they are
it is bizarre you've never seen that
thing i i hadn't seen it until this week
have you guys seen the old documentary
the queen of versailles
did you see that yeah that's a timeshare
king yeah
building a 90 000 square foot house with
his wife who's 30 years his junior
wow and and all that that implies
a thousand huh 90 000 square foot house
the largest house in america
yeah so we're going to talk about that
kind of stuff it's fun but that that
that documentary was just a train wreck
of people it was
such sad just because they're just it's
just like god who lives like this well
they do yeah and that's who's selling
you this stuff so
anyway email us at dave on air i'm sorry
dave on air at ramseysolutions.com and
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
jimmy and stacy are with us hey guys how
are you they're doing great how are you
better than i deserve where do you guys
live we are from not survivors of
chicago
okay very cool good to have you guys and
you're here to do a debt free scream how
much did you pay off
so as a married couple
um we did 153
114 dollars great um
how long did that take uh 18 months five
days
all right and your range of income
during that year and a half
so that was 2 15 to 2 about 2 50.
wow what do you guys do for a living i'm
a pharmacist
and i'm in the i.t very good good for
you guys
what kind of debt was the 153 thousand
um as part of my student loan debt
that's been following me around before
marriage
um so i uh you said as a married couple
at the front of this so
you're telling me that before you were
married there's other stuff happened
it's the student loan debt it's been
haunting me for a long time but had you
reduced it substantially prior to
marriage
uh 96 thousand 47.
yeah it took me yeah it took me quite a
while to even get that as a single
parent
but when we got married it was just boom
just go through it hot and fast
good for you well done so how long have
you guys been married 18 months
uh no so well a little closer two years
now
okay all right so but the last year and
a half or so
uh all through covet boom boom he was
hospitalized
he had a surgery at the end of the year
i had a surgery on my foot so we had a
lot of
really weird um things that
sort of sidetracked us we were expecting
to be done a little bit earlier but 18
months are still pretty impressive yeah
yeah i was
glad we were still able to get through i
was sad going into 2021 with the debt
but it's still february at the end of
february
and you still did it in the pandemic
year yes yeah we kept
no interest on student loans oh i was so
excited about that
because you can make so much faster
progress yeah yeah i mean when it's all
said and done
i paid eighty-five thousand thirty nine
dollars ninety four cents in interest
wow from the beginning oh yeah so what
sparked
this thing um so i heard about dave a
few years ago and
i kind of did davish you know where it's
like yeah i want to do this but then i
it was really hard my income wasn't
there i was supposed to be guaranteed
full-time hours i wasn't getting it
i was applying for jobs not really
getting a whole lot so i was kind of
driving all over the state of florida
to be able to make ends meet and
pay my little student loan that i was
getting which was mostly going to
interest i was doing income based
repayment which
you don't get anywhere pretty much
actually lower you're going backwards
yeah
so um when i moved to illinois um
i i decided i was going to do like the
full baby steps now i hadn't done
financial peace university in fact um he
actually ended up doing it before me and
he hadn't even heard of you so i
introduced him to you
and he is the spender the flashy guy
i wasn't sure that our relationship was
going to go very far when i first
started dating him because we were on
different pages
and i will honestly say i did not tell
him he had to
listen to you that was the lord there
and he came to me one day
after he started financial peace
university and brought me his cut up
credit cards
and i was like thank you lord
i think this is my only one yeah this is
it that
and that was not me badgering him or
anything so smooth romantic move
[Laughter]
that's very cool so jimmy when you were
hospitalized was it coveted or something
else that is crazy oh really with covet
yeah yeah
and you're a young guy not quite i'm 40
years old
yeah well i'm 16. that's not old so all
right you're a young guy
i'm a young guy all right very cool good
for you
and so you got out of it okay though
yeah it was a pretty rough
rough ride i was i almost died oh my
gosh
he ended up being out of work um i was
able to take off work to stay home and
help him i mean he literally had to
learn how to
walk and have strength to walk and even
hold a spoon so oh my goodness
yeah i'm just we're a really nasty case
then
yeah wow well i'm so glad you're here
and everything's good
yeah so all of this and you still paid
off 153 000 in 18 months
yes yes in the first two years of
marriage
you guys are impressive he cut up his
credit cards
yeah that's how he got me that's it
wow way to go guys yeah very very cool
my daughter isabella just graduated high
school
on was that friday okay congratulations
very cool congrats isabella very neat
what a great year then
things are going well how's it feel to
be free
i can't even ex it's just amazing
and i'm just looking forward to the
future what do you tell people the key
to getting out of that is
just you got to be focused and look at
the end
what do you want at the end that that
point what are you getting what was your
big why what was your big push
um so i really didn't want my daughter
to ever being in debt and she um
she was with me when i was a new
christian i started learning
about christian principles and one of
those being the
bar servant to the lender and i looked
back and said if i could do it all over
again i would have did it a lot
differently
but when we didn't really have the
income
there was a time i thought we might
actually be homeless i know it sounds
nuts
being a pharmacist and not being able to
get a job and
i believe it i mean i literally was
picking up shifts driving all over the
state of florida
and um you know i remember having
conversations with her and
one of her prayers she made a scroll she
was in a sunday school class she made a
little scroll
and the kids wrote a prayer that they
had well her prayer was
for me to get out of debt and um i
carried that around in my pocket
up until i got out of debt in my jacket
my white coat i
carried it around and when i would go to
pull a pen out or something i would fill
it and i know that
you know i'm i'm in this i may not be
enjoying every day and i may be stressed
out some days but
um i don't want that for her and she's
so diverse
and um so yeah she has her first
semester already paid for
all right well isabel get up in this get
up in the shot when they do their debt
free scream here you're part of this
story
very cool way to go jimmy and say see we
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the next
chapter in your story leaving a legacy
changed your legacy
now become very wealthy and outrageously
generous in the process
and you've changed your family tree
we're so proud of you also got a copy of
the total money makeover for you to give
away pay it forward get somebody else
moving
and show them how to do it that's great
stuff jimmy stacy and isabella from
chicago
153 000 paid off in 18 months making 215
to 250.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
five more three two one
[Applause]
that is how it's done
wow what a story this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five tyler is with us in fort
worth texas hey tyler how are you
hey dave and dr john how are y'all
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
um dave is such an honor to speak with
you um my girlfriend and i we attended
your reset live event in oklahoma
back in january and we really enjoyed it
so it was my first time seeing you and
it was great to see the team too so
thank you thank you that was a good
night dr john you're
you're a great addition too i really i'm
a really interested thanks man
okay so here here's my numbers um i'm 22
years old
very recently graduated with a
construction science degree
basically construction management in two
weeks i started my new job
at a company that i previously interned
with i'll be making roughly 60 thousand
dollars gross
and i will i will be living at home with
my parents i've been listening to your
show
almost every day for about a year and a
half now i'm on baby step two
um and here are some other quick numbers
i have sixty six thousand two hundred
dollars in student loan debt
no they're debt no credit card no car
loan um but there's some good news i
cash cashflowed my senior year of
college
and i have an additional twenty five
thousand eight hundred dollars ready to
be utilized for that
at this moment okay so
i also have um an e-trade account with
two single stocks in it that i was given
um during my sophomore year of college
this was
unbeknownst to me came out of nowhere
that value today is right around 13 000
so i basically have two scenarios i'm
going to put that 25 800 towards the
debt
which will bring me down to 40 grand and
then i have two options i can use that
13 grand
i mean can be all debt um random numbers
in 12 months
or not use that um 13 000
and be out of debt in 18 months now the
difference with six months
but my thought was i could instead of
investing those
um 13 grand into single stocks i can put
that in some usual funds and let that
start growing
now so what do you think dave
well we teach folks to clean out any
assets that they have that are not in a
retirement plan
and use them to clear their debts as
fast as they can because the shortest
distance between where you earn wealth
is not an e-trade account the shortest
distance between where you are in wealth
is to be debt-free and get control of
your largest wealth building tool which
is your income
so we're going to clean out everything
down to a thousand dollars okay and
we're going to throw out all of this
debt and then we're going beans and rice
rice and beans
no goofing off no spending money and
clean the rest of this up
really really really fast
yes sir yeah i i've been going back and
forth with this for about
a year now since i called the show maybe
a year ago i didn't know what to do with
it then
did i tell you what to do with the
directly no no i didn't no you didn't
then um
i talked to john and uh anthony but
okay so are you are you going to be
myself so yeah yeah
i'm going to sell yeah i'm going to sell
it
okay good good do it right now yeah
today
curtis is with us in sioux falls south
dakota hi curtis welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave thank you for taking the call
sure how can we help
a little back story in 2019
my folks started going through a divorce
and they own a construction company
and they volunteered to make me a 10
owner
before the divorce was filed
it's been a two-year battle since then
uh we've turned the company around a lot
and we did a mediation yesterday
and i'm kind of torn on how to do some
of the financing of the buyout
you're buying them out i'm
uh my dad is buying my mom out and i'm
just kind of helping him along the way
okay you're helping him by advising him
correct correct yes you're not
co-signing for him
no no i can't no okay
okay and so what is that i don't know
has the amount been determined
yes how much 400 000.
you guys have done well since 2019
we've done very well in fact
how much cash is in the business
uh as of right now because we were going
into mediation i kept the cash very low
and we updated a lot of machines
so we walked into mediation with under
10 000 in cash
well that worked real good for the
mediation but it doesn't work real good
for the buyout
no but i'm exactly where it was two
years ago financially
okay so what kind of profit will this
place generate in the next 12 months
um i'm contracted
for roughly eight hundred thousand
profit
in that range profit will pay her off in
12 months
right i've also got other outstanding
deaths from
machine purchases in the last are they
short-term debts
five-year we'll pay her off in the next
12 months
okay you have 800 000 you need 400
right right what am i missing yeah what
are we missing man
it seems fairly obvious right i just
i've got a lot of numbers in my head the
last couple days let me tell you what's
really in your head
what all of you are pissed off at her
and don't want to give her the money
oh i have no problem giving her the
money your dad does i know what well
yeah
probably okay and this is affecting your
judgment because for
for me it's a very simple 800 000 over
the next 12 months i think you two guys
can figure out a way to get you a bloney
sandwich out of that
and pay this woman off and get her out
of make her the ex-wife
okay give her her money now
and then you go deal with your machinery
and get your other stuff other debts
cleaned up as soon as you can
this is a priority for a lot of reasons
it's going to set you guys emotionally
relationally free to go do business
again
because having a bulldozer payment is
way different than having an ex-wife
payment
i mean exactly they're kind of similar
they're very similar but
it's going to let you say it first
[Laughter]
but there's some there's something about
like
that is as simple as math gets yeah
there's
there's an emotional blocker is what it
is big time yeah so you make it a
priority
like you wanted to do it yeah and if you
walk in and show up
any banker on earth hey i've got hundred
thousand dollars of contracts here
i need to make a i mean well you don't
even you can just pay her out of cash
flow
she can't do anything in the next six
months anyway so just pay her out of
cash flow
just pay her i mean if she gets her
money inside 12 months that's going to
work on the mediation believe me
for wrapping up a divorce that's already
18 months in yeah that tells me that's
contentious and dramatic yeah
and a lot of moving parts so walk me
through dave real quick
what would not go into cash at a
mediation is that like some kind of move
i don't get the chest he's trying to
prove he was broke in order to make the
business worth less
so that she only got a valuation of
eight hundred grand
get your mom and move on dude
congratulations now
cash for does not also mean equal broke
they look at net worth they look at cash
flow
you know you va you don't value a
business based on the number of dozers
and
like a cash you value a business based
on um
based on its income that it creates and
that's what
the valuation comes from it sounds like
this was dramatically undervalued
so i would have yeah it's i would have
rather flipped that over and been able
to walk out
yesterday like this yeah had had a half
million dollars in the account and paid
her a half million instead of four
hundred and then
lost a little bit of the mediation but
there's a lot going on in this story
that you and i are not hearing that's
true
i can promise you there's a lot of stuff
here
it's amazing full-on reality show for
the last 24 months
yeah yeah get her paid off fast you can
man that's the bottom line of the thing
that's
the trick as fast as you want to do as
fast you can possibly
do that and for future reference
be careful when you uh implement
a short-term strategy that has
negative long-term effects but feels
good in the moment where you
tried to make the company worth less
because you bled it out of cash and
bought all this equipment now you put
the company deeply in debt so in the
short term you fix the problem with your
mom's mediation and your dad's mediation
but on the long term you put your
company deeply in debt and you cause
long-term problems for a short-term
issue and so that you have to be careful
in business
or in your personal life it's like
someone goes you know transmissions out
again i'm buying a brand new 86 000 car
you know and so you fix a temporary
problem with a permanent
with a five-year permanent drama yeah
and um
a long-term problem and that's what
everybody tends to do but that's emotion
driven
more often than it is breaks my heart
for that side yeah what a mess
of this dr john delonie good show good
hour this
good hour on the show today james childs
our producer kelly daniel our associate
producer i'm dave ramsey we'll be back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
dolone ramsey personality best-selling
author and host of the dr john deloney
show
a very famous podcast and youtube show
where you can join him there
all the time and answer questions about
mental health relationships anxiety
all kinds of fun things and the show is
um well it's uh
it's moving and it's inspiring and it's
entertaining
so be sure and check out the dr john
delony show
next hour i will be talking about
america continue talking about america's
greatest legal fraud
time shares if you have a time share or
you have been ripped off by a timeshare
company or you want to talk about the
scummy sales process that the timeshare
companies use
call in talk to kelly or email us at
dave on air at ramseysolutions.com and
you can be part of the show
next hour we want real people with real
time share stories
i've certainly got my opinions and
they're right but we would love to hear
from you
if you want to know what it's like to
work for dave ramsey that was it
that was it right that was it that
solved it right there so folks if
uh you're an employer listen up
one of the things we've discovered here
years ago and we were one of the first
to discover this
is the way that productivity with
employees
is affected by their personal life and
that includes their money
if your team member is struggling with
money and they're getting
calls from discover card and mastercard
they are not thinking about work at work
uh in a manufacturing setting that can
even be dangerous
uh in the military it can be dangerous
because you need your eye on the
you know you're eye on the ball there or
if they're working for you and they are
applying to every other job
under the sun trying to get a raise
mornings at night trying to yeah
money stress is everywhere so we uh
i think we invented the phrase we
actually own it anyway
financial wellness because there are all
these wellness movements in corporate
america
and so we put financial wellness in
there we own financialwellness.com
money stress is everywhere and if you
want proof we did a recent study with
our research team that
found half of all employers say
financial stress has a significant
impact on their employees but only 30
percent of companies
have a financial wellness program well
that seems counterproductive
yeah so if your employee stress is
hurting your company
because it's hurting their lives you
could help them and
help your company and that would be like
something that would be smart to do you
get a return on investment there
don't ignore the problem uh this
research paper is pretty incredible that
we did on the details of this
and i know running a business has been
tough and i know the last year you're
thinking about a lot of stuff financial
wellness may not have been on the list
of things you're trying to
make payroll friday that kind of stuff
right uh but you got a shot to help your
team here
and i think the shot they've is we hear
this all the time it's bigger than
teaching them money principles it
teaches them intentionality principles
it teaches them hey here's how to get
your life in order and man if you can
get your employees to start
thinking bigger about what they're doing
and why they're doing it how they're
doing it and you start mapping out your
day
and your week and your month you're
going to see a more engaged employee a
more intentional human being coming to
work every day
yeah right and we teach this stuff and
we didn't we want to make sure our team
was not ramsey-ish
yeah so we uh actually initiated some of
our leadership team got
really fired up about it this year and
initiated a whole program internally
here called walk the talk
if you're going to say this is what we
do maybe you ought to be doing it
exactly right don't be a hypocrite
and so we've got t-shirts and banners
and everything all over the building
walk the talk walk through we had
financial peace university down here in
our main lobby on the in the evenings
and
you know 500 600 people went through it
of the thousand that most of them had
already been through it
uh before but they're going through it
again and the amount of debt our team
has paid off since the first of the year
is pretty amazing it's inspiring
so if you're in hr you're a decision
maker at your company you want to hear
about this stuff
about financial wellness and you want to
see what this study says this free
report
our 2021 smart dollar financial wellness
benefits study it's real easy to do
there's a ton of information here text
wellness
233 789 and you can get this free
report it is in depth our 2021 research
paper
smart dollar financial wellness benefits
study
ton of great information text wellness
two
three three seven eight
nine john is in los angeles hi
john welcome to the ramsey show
i think you're taking my call sure man
what's up
so i have an anxiety question i'm happy
that dr john's on the line as well
so i'm 28 years old my wife and i are on
baby steps
four five and six and i grew up in a
paycheck to paycheck castle
and now i'm about two years out of law
school my wife and i
paid off all my law school loans
together in about 13 months
way to go man and so we're debt-free now
but
now i have trouble spending money on
anything and
it's not like i'm scared of the future i
trust that god will provide and
i also are you on a speaker phone
john can you hear me now yeah it's a
little better
go ahead apologies okay you could
go ahead i was saying
i'm okay with saving a bit and i'm not
afraid of the future or anything like
that but i just feel real guilty
spending money on anything
there's a lot of you know impoverished
men and homelessness and
los angeles where i live and so i just i
feel a lot of anxiety about
and guilt about spending any money
what do you do with the money that you
don't spend
save it we give a lot um and that's it
really
i like spending money on my wife i like
buying her things but
she keeps trying to get me to to buy
something from me and i can't
seem to do it who told you you weren't
worth taking care of
um you know what i don't think but yeah
somebody did
somebody told you that you come last
your oxygen mask goes on last
that it's all right to take care of
everybody else but
the moment you start experiencing joy
you get this
man you've done something wrong you've
stepped over into dangerous territory
who told
you that probably
someone at church okay
yeah they can be expert um
what do you say dave about guilt trips
yeah expert travel agent for guilty yeah
they can be travel agents for guilt
trips there that's right
hey listen that's that's a it's a
somebody lied to you brother
i'm sorry so here's the thing
um
it shows a big heart of compassion
that you notice the homeless around you
you also are able to do first grade math
and you know that you're not the messiah
and you can't take care of them
all right you can you can help with the
homeless issue by making some donations
to the
local mission or do other people that
are doing good homeless programs
um but even that is not going to fix the
homeless problem
because you didn't ever buy you a shirt
does that make sense right right yeah
when i start doing stuff
like this uh my wife goes hey you ain't
the messiah
that's his job the job's taken
and it's good to have a big heart and be
compassionate
but it but when it overwhelms you to the
point that you are
unable to do the normal rhythms of life
uh because you see
need out there that's a messiah complex
you're starting to think you're jesus
it's not your job it's his job a job's
taken
and you're not big enough to do it i'm
not big enough to do it none of us are
big enough to fix
that single-handedly with our own
personal checkbook
i mean even bill gates couldn't do that
right
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career
training and a paycheck to help you
avoid debt no matter what your goals are
the army national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
john is in los angeles we ran him up
into the commercial and crashed him
uh and he was talking about how to
learn to enjoy money uh without feeling
guilty now that he got out of debt
uh delony more uh comments on that yeah
here's what i want you to do man i want
you to begin to consider yourself worthy
of taking care of too
and most of us have to it's going to
sound counterintuitive because we think
we just
we just are born into the world knowing
how to do this and we don't
but i want you to begin to practice
if you've got the money i've paid it off
everything you're in baby steps four
five and six
you're a lawyer you're doing okay i want
you to
practice spending money on yourself
what's an example of something you would
buy that you would feel guilty about
um pretty much anything
well give me an example like going out
some afghanistan
okay all right so i i think for a little
while to learn to develop the muscle
john's suggesting you learn to develop
this muscle put it as a line item in
your budget
john that's the line item
and that money cannot be spent on
anything that's in that
line item you can do an envelope put the
cash in an envelope write john on it
it cannot be spent on anything except
john i had to do this john because my
wife was doing the same thing
she's a classic um southern belle
and uh you know uh well we'll say we'll
have plenty of money for the children's
clothes and i'll just wear the drapes
like she's scarlet o'hara right
martyrdom yeah right martyrdom
and so i finally had to set it aside a
separate clothing on my
sharon's clothing kid's clothing you
cannot spend sharon's clothing money on
anything except sharon's clothing
right then that takes all the guilt out
of it so after years of practice
budgeted is she coming around she has no
trouble now
trouble whatsoever now she's completely
healed she is healed she's healed
she's miracle she's a professional
nicole all right allison
is in phoenix arizona hey allison what's
up
well i am debt three love it how much
have you paid off
120 000.
46 months 46 months making what kind of
money range during that time
so i started my base salary with my
full-time position
started with 57 000 and
i am ending at 80 000 but with my
side hustles that i did multiples of
um my one year was a hundred and six
thousand
way to go what kind of uh debt was the
120
so the vast majority was my student loan
for my doctorate degree
which allowed me to then have a side
hustle that was a pretty significant ad
what is your document and um it's in
education
very good very good so what started what
started the
journey to get out of debt 46 months ago
well it was looking at myself
that i should have had i stayed in
another position i could have been
retired by now
and i had a lot of challenges i
went for four years where i was
unemployed and underemployed and i
went two full years unemployed and then
two more years making
twenty thousand dollars a year trying to
make things work and then lots of life
in between and um i came back found my
passionate job
here in arizona and uh
realized i could be retiring in 10 or 12
years
and i don't have any money to do that
and
i said i need to retire with dignity
because i'm
not going to put my children through
taking care of me
as i took care of my parents hey allison
it's easy to focus on the money part but
i want to spend two seconds on
being out of work for four years making
20 000
that is a psychological beating that's a
spiritual beating
what what what brought you back to your
feet
and said you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna take this one little step and
another step another step and you took
off
to side note i asked for taking
ownership of your future
what what what motivates you to do that
to side note
i asked for a call when you would be on
dr dillon
because i love you um so
i i was i've been a single parent
for nearly the entirety of my children's
life
and um my parents were gambling addicts
and i grew up in a household i know this
is like a long way to your answer but i
grew up in a household
that didn't take care of money
and so i learned how to really be good
at
being in debt and in 2006
i discovered a different person who said
get proof your life
don't get free but get proof your life
so i tried that
and um it that
introduced me to dave ramsey but i
didn't believe in dave ramsey
until i lost my job and my house
and my ability to take care of my family
and then my mother passed away and my
father moved in with me and
also i took care of him and so
it was it was hard it was my
you found yourself out of options huh i
didn't know what to do i thought
i thought i've gotten debt proofed
before
i can do it again so the first two years
i was kind of okay
and i was like i've done this before i
can do it again
and it just the debt just kept growing
and growing
and growing because i didn't follow the
baby step plan right i didn't have the
rest of the plan
i got out of debt but i didn't follow
the whole plan
and um and then after two years
then depression set in and i didn't
believe in myself and then i gave up i
was like well
you know heck who cares you know i can't
take it with me
my parents didn't take it with them i
can't take it with me
and and so what does it matter anymore
if i'm in debt and then
i came back to arizona i had moved away
and came back and found my passion
job i love what i do and i love where i
work
and i finally started healing
my um sense of self and my sense of
self-worth
and that's when i was able to then turn
around and say
yeah that's foundation
you're ready to go allison very well
done
thank you we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
uh you have changed your
life but now you're gonna change your
legacy so continue with this we're very
very proud of you you have really
you're you're a superhero you've
persevered
awesome absolutely amazing very well
done also a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and get
somebody on their journey
and teach them the baby steps that it
took you a while to learn there
so proud of you kiddo very well done
all right it's allison in phoenix
arizona 120
thousand dollars paid off in 46 months
making 57-80 to 106.
she's hustling and grinding count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done you know it is
foundational to be able to do
the baby steps to get to ground zero
yeah
and when you're struggling through
uh so many holes you're down in a hole
yeah you got to get up to ground level
to start and it feels like a war to get
to zero to get up to to get up to ground
level yeah
to get past the the addictive behavior
and grow in their home of origin to get
past
the i'm not worth anything yeah
hopelessness the worthlessness to get up
to there
and then all of a sudden when you're
standing on that base ground even at
zero and you can see your way up the
light comes on it's like hope
yeah yeah man it's powerful to stud well
done kiddo well done this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
allen and ashley are with us hey guys
how are you
good how are you dave welcome it's a
pleasure to have you where do you guys
live
charlotte north carolina very good and
you're here to do a debt-free scream how
much did you pay off
oh you're looking at weird people dave
you paid off your house paid off her
house
yeah 393 000 total
all right wow how long did this take you
uh close to five years or four to five
years good for you and your range of
income through that five years
it's like 90 to 260. wow what do you
guys do for a living
uh we work in transportation i'm a
freight broker i'm a dispatcher
okay cool is this how you all met no
believe it or not i was a salesman in
new york we're from new york connecticut
area
and um she was one of my customers and i
kept hitting on her and
she wasn't interested and then i moved
down to charlotte and eventually i
reeled her in
you know ah that's a good salesman yeah
well played
charlotte charlotte was a good move yes
good for you so what inspired you five
years ago to get house and
everything paid off well we just didn't
want to be a part of the rat race
anymore for me i would always complain
to my friends and co-workers about hated
work and like a day job and doing the
nine to five and
just had to find a way to get out so we
decided to just do nothing but work
for four or five years doing side
hustles full-time jobs
managing around the kids schedule yeah
i'd work a full-time job monday through
friday
and then once my son went to bed i'd go
out and i'd door dash or
grubhub or whatever side hustle i had to
do wow and then on the weekends i go
during his nap time and bedtime and
wow just whenever we could to make the
extra money i mean there's no fun
right now but we'll be there yeah you
can have any kind of fun you want now
making a couple of hundred and no
payments no house payment or anything
how's it feel to be completely free
great great it feels um like a huge
relief
to just was it worth all the sacrifice
absolutely we don't even know how to get
out of it we talk about that
like we don't need to work all the time
but we're still working seven days a
week around our kids schedule it's like
how do you break that trend after doing
it for so long you
you feel unproductive when you're not
working so it's like i'm on the couch
for like an hour watching tv i feel like
i should be out working
she's the same way so interesting cool
well you need a hobby yeah we do there's
these two magic words i want to teach
you you ready i
quit you can use them on the way home
to whoever they apply to congratulations
thank you very much
very very strong way to go guys so what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is you pay off
393 000 house and everything
what do you say uh dedication just stick
with it keep going and then
at the end it will be nice not to have
to worry about you know when the utility
bill comes in am i going to pay this
week or i'm gonna wait till the next
paycheck
now it just comes in and you can just
pay it right off
and for me it's just um
i want to make sure that that the rest
of my life you know my son doesn't have
to grow up the way that i grew up
and for me i grew up poor in a very
wealthy neighborhood in connecticut and
everyone around me was rich and i was
far from that so i just tell people
stick with it
and the grass is always greener on the
other side
so how old are your kids man i got a
three-year-old
a three-year-old three-year-old and a
15-year-old wow that's perfect
what's this house worth uh probably
around well with this crazy white market
we're in now yeah
our realtor's telling us about 450. yeah
i love it yeah way to go thank you
yeah so you got to feel completely
different
it does it's just nice like i always
tell my boss all the time like this is
the last day job i'm ever going gonna
have i like working here so i choose to
work here
but like i don't feel like i need to
work 40 50 hours a week anymore
changing the same way yeah so wow so
what actions are you gonna take when you
get home
to plug into this three-year-old instead
of more door-to-door
well we try to do family time on the
weekends
um she's always home to put him to bed
and read him a bedtime story and
um but yeah for the most part we got to
spend more time together with
them which seems to be the problem it's
like one of us is always working all the
time
so our schedule's kind of built around
him but you're right we do need to
figure that out more very exciting yeah
we both work from home so that's a plus
side
oh okay so i mean he gets to stay home
with us at all times and yeah he's never
seen a daycare in his life
yeah that's wonderful and you got all
these goals hit yeah that's very
powerful
good all right well let's get him in the
shot what is his name and age again
austin and he's three austin
three-year-old austin
allen and ashley from charlotte north
carolina
they're weird people they paid off their
house and everything in five years 393
000 paid off and of course
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you you have changed your legacy
you've changed your family tree i'm so
proud of y'all
thank you dave appreciate it very well
done excellent excellent work good job
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away to someone as they
head off in the right
direction as well so good stuff all
right alan ashley and austin let's hear
a debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
look at the smile on his face
[Laughter]
he loves the applause yes he does well
that's what happens when your mom and
dad are studs that's amazing
wow very powerful stuff
see if you make i mean let's just say
they quit
a whole bunch of their jobs and they
only make 150 yes
and you don't have a house payment you
become
very wealthy real fast if you just
invest the house payment right if that's
all you do take your house payment round
it up
have it automatically drafted out of
your checking account that account alone
will become a million dollars so fast
it'll take care of you it will blow your
mind
how quickly this thing turns in the
other direction
and the momentum that you've pushed for
so long to try to get that rock up the
hill
finally it goes over the top and it's
rolling down the other side yeah and
then you get to find a new
you spent four years cranking on that y
and now you get to sit down and
do what i think's a lot of fun is dream
and create a new one yeah what's next
right
it's a little three-year-old right there
right that's 15 year old at home that's
awesome what's the what's the next
big push that's the thing very very cool
stuff
well one of the things that happens when
you get all of your debts paid off and
you don't have
any debt of any kind on your fico
on your credit report at all your fico
score becomes zero
dave doesn't that mean you're dead
[Laughter]
no it means you have a lot of money
i can buy anything i want to buy
and i don't have a fico score because i
have money and i have money because i
don't have a fico score
because the only way you get a fico
score is going to stay in debt and pay
it all the time
and the same is true when you teach your
kids so they teach that three-year-old
it's uh teach your kids to be cultural
in a culture that worships at the altar
of the great fico
oh great fico you are our provider oh
thank you
good old fake who so we just dropped
prices up to 80
on our best-selling kids products so you
can have fun
and education this summer for the kiddos
the adventure pack is a family favorite
that includes the new story time
collection
financial peace junior the smart saver
bank
and more to make learning about money
actually
fun and the best part is you can add an
extra kit
for each sibling or if you've got a teen
that's wanting to earn some extra cash
the teen entrepreneur
toolbox is the perfect safe and flexible
way for them to create their own summer
jobs
they'll turn hobbies into real
businesses and they'll learn hard work
leadership
and responsibility teach them the right
way to handle money
while they're young save up to 80
percent off
by shopping the kids and teens sale
at the online store at
ramseysolutions.com
store ramsey solutions dot com slash
store
so you're teaching the kiddos and the
deloney household
yeah we in fact i was just thinking last
night i was uh
actually i thought man i can't get away
from dave i was laying down
reading my daughter a story to go to
sleep and i looked over and
saw her ramsay um
you know it's like a piggy bank but it's
divided up into those three sections so
she gets a representation of pictures
man her and hank are working hard this
summer and hank's starting his hank's
handyman service
taking care of some of our um aging
neighbors their farms and places and
man watching them put it in the save and
in the spin
watching him work hard and then buy a
lego set he wants just so great
that's powerful yeah it's cool man good
stuff that's how you change the family
tree yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today coming up at the top of
the hour
we're going to do a another hour on the
time share industry america's largest
legal
fraud if you want to comment on that you
want to be part of that hour you can
call in
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five 5225 or you can email and
kelly will get you set up
at dave on air at ramseysolutions.com
we have room for you to tell your
timeshare horror
story or if you know someone that has
one get on the phone with them and tell
them to
get in touch with us right now and they
can be part of this
so in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the
debt free stage is danielle from
colorado springs with a question hi
danielle how are you
hi i'm actually from austin colorado but
i'm doing great and thank you for
letting me ask my question today
sure what's up well my husband and i
recently reached baby step seven
and uh we're both teachers and we're way
to go yeah wow
we're struggling with our will because
while we completed the journey very
successfully
our children um we did not change the
family tree and so we're struggling with
knowing um
how to um put this all in our will while
including
what we've started as our legacy and how
to talk to them about it without
alienating them or without trying to
change who they are
so what does that mean who they are um
they didn't
we live the baby steps out loud it's in
my classroom it's in the community i'm a
financial peace university coordinator
so it's no secret we even threw a party
for my husband's truck when it turned
30.
so it's no secret that we are living the
steps
out loud and they didn't choose to
follow us because they were older when
we got married
and so um we're we're doing all sorts of
crazy things that we're really excited
about
we want to include it in our will but we
don't know what it looks like
for people that don't understand where
we're coming from we don't want to
feel like we're judging them because
it's their life they're adults but
we wish that we had changed the family
tree of our four children
one of them is doing well one of them is
doing ish and the other two was like
who's dave ramsey
that kind of thing and we we don't want
to alienate them
and we don't want to judge them out loud
we wish that they would take the journey
but
um we're really passionate about we have
a memorial scholarship in my brother's
name it's really taken off it's really
doing great
we're going to put that that's going to
be in our will but we disagree
on what to say when to say it and what
we should do
so i'm going to let dave talk through
the will i want
to let you know that judging a family
tree
while you're still here is often too
soon
yeah true and so right when you said
that i just wrote a note and i wrote yet
right and what i'll tell you is kids
often especially when it's
they get to see an example not just hear
words they get to see it
they often loop back around right and
there will come a moment when they go oh
i don't have anything that's my mom and
dad
and then then they come crawling back
and say tell me about this
this dave guy right so don't wear that
baggage yet
okay um dave what do you think about
this will situation
um so here's the thing
let's say that someone was working here
on our team
and i'm giving them my money to do work
and um they're not doing a good job
not talking to them about that and
calling that
not being judgmental is inaccurate
it's also unkind because i owe them
the feedback to be able to change their
lives to become a good
team member to become productive as a
team member that way they get to keep
their job
otherwise i just walk in and they
randomly get fired they don't know what
happened
because i refused to judge them because
all along
i was judging them you're supposed to
judge people by the way
you're supposed to judge them this idea
that oh you can't judge people yet you
actually
you're supposed to and you need to uh
you don't have to be a jerk about it
you don't have to be judgmental but it
is unkind
to share with those that you love the
most
a better way of life it's unkind to not
share with them
yeah to to to not share with them yeah i
mean to to hold back and go well that's
just the way they're made no they're not
made that way i mean
you know it's not
not saving money is not a character
trait it's a decision
well i that's what makes it hard is
because they don't understand or support
the decisions that we've made which is
fine yeah they don't have to do that
but they do have to start behaving in
such a way that they're going to receive
my money
or they don't receive it okay and it's
unkind for you to have
because here's the thing if they're
misbehaving
and you give them money you are now
funding the misbehavior that's the
ultimate in enabling
right and so an extreme example that is
they're doing heroin
but they hit the dna lottery so they're
happy to be my kid that's a heroin
addict
but i can't judge them oh yes i can
you're a heroin addict i just judged you
and i'm not giving you money upon my
death to further damage your life with
your misbehavior
you'll die of an overdose that's an
extreme example but this is a minor
example where
a series of choices going
unaddressed by them or you
funded with a big pile of money is going
to magnify the negative
that's what i was worried about you're
because what money does is it doesn't
it doesn't heal things it magnifies the
good things and the bad things
and we've all got some of both by the
way so and you are spending a lot of
energy
judging you and your husband what do you
mean
you you have these values and you're
almost like you're ashamed of us yeah
no i'm not i'm very i'm i'm sad
that they didn't when you when you ask
people what the hardest part of the
journey is i would
clearly say that it's they that they
didn't join us yeah so
yeah yes yeah and so i i think i would
just sit down and say listen
you're adults i i am not in a position
to tell you what you have to do to live
or how to live and i am not going to do
that but it would be
unclear of me and unkind to me for
you to not understand that as long as
you're
not handling money in a way that i view
reasonable
i can't leave you money so you won't be
in the will
right and i i don't want to get off the
stage without saying that we love all of
our kids
equally i didn't right i know you didn't
say that i just want them to hear this
and think
wow we just wish better for them yeah
yeah yeah i mean think of it this way if
a truck was coming
and they're in the middle of the road
yeah you would shove them out of the way
right
and it would be unkind to say well i
don't want to i don't want to
judge your behavior i don't want yeah
they're they're dancing i don't want to
get in the middle of that yeah they're
definitely going to hit him
doing tequila shots and dancing in the
middle of the road yeah right i mean
it's a problem it's a problem
so uh but but you know i'm i can't make
you do anything but i can
not give you money for the tequila i
mean i can i cannot
fund the misbehavior and it's just a
loving thing it's you know you want to
be very brief
and very kind and very gentle very low
and and don't get into a bunch of your
disappointment i won't it's just
i need to give you the information that
we're not going to be sharing wealth
with people
who um don't share our value who don't
share a value and can't handle it
uh because i'm afraid it's going to
bring you harm instead of a blessing and
i love you too much to give you anything
except a blessing
and so you have my spiritual blessing
you'll always have my love
but you won't have my money it'll be
left to something else
unless you guys want to learn how to do
this stuff and anytime you do
we're here to help but we're not going
to interfere in your lives your adults
right
does that sound balanced it does you've
reached a point where you have to pick
your heart
you want to live in distress of you're
going to violate your own values by
giving money to people that you don't
think is going to be a good steward of
it
or you're going to live in distress
you're going to have a hard season of
here's our boundaries and we're going to
hold firm to him you got to pick your
heart right yeah
it's not an emergency or anything but i
i um
you know our will is very detailed on
this stuff
um and even further controlling
than what we're discussing right now and
so
um because we're christians and we
believe
that uh where it's not really our money
we're managing it
and i can't leave god's money to a
an unrighteous or an incompetent
manager and so if you're going to be
doing a bunch of
crazy stuff normal stuff yeah doing
cocaine on the back of a yacht and
thinking you're shooting a reality show
because you're a trust fund baby you're
confused if you're a ramsay because
you're going to get zip
i'm not funding that because of your
lifestyle decisions and because i love
you too much to fund your cocaine habits
and the important thing is that you told
them that up front oh yeah
they know yeah they're all clear in the
ramsey it's a it's a
responsibility of management that you're
losing
not hitting the lottery there you go
that's a difference
it's a different viewpoint on it thank
you so much very nice
john good hour thank you well done james
childs kelly daniels
up next timeshare hour
yeah call in people
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsey show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
a couple of weeks ago i stepped onto the
air
and started talking to you guys about
the timeshare industry
now i pick on rent to own guys
payday lenders credit card companies
car leases whole life companies
all for one reason and one reason only
because they screw
you the consumer
their rip-offs they're not good for you
they don't cause you to win i have
not advocated for legislation to
ban them because i would rather you guys
just put them out of business by
stopping
your use of payday lenders if i could
educate enough people how bad payday
lenders are they would quit going to
them
and then they would dry up and they
would go away if i could tell enough
people to buy term insurance instead of
whole life insurance i would
and then there would be i don't need
legislation to put
whole life life insurance out of
business instead education and
inspiration will do that i've been doing
this for 30 years
and all during the time i've been on the
air and the time i've been doing
financial coaching i am meeting people
who have been screwed
by the timeshare industry
they go in on a vacation
and they're told if they come to a short
sales presentation which will end up
being from
five to eight hours long
that they get a free hotel room
well that's not free
and then they buy something from eight
thousand dollars to a hundred and eight
thousand dollars
where they have the rights to use
a hotel room a condominium
for one week or two weeks or three weeks
or four weeks a year
they have absolutely no title to the
real estate
they bought air
and they know they bought air when they
try to sell it or get rid of it because
you can't sell it it's not an asset
they're all over ebay for a dollar and
no one will buy them for a dollar
because then you've signed up for the
ridiculous
ever increasing maintenance fees where
they gig you and gig you and gig you and
gig you and gig you and gig you over and
over and over again
this is a 10 billion dollar industry
they take a simple condominium project
that they would have made a few million
dollars on
and they make hundreds of millions of
dollars by selling it by the hour and by
the week
to people who then own nothing
and they're in debt many times for 15 or
20 or 30 thousand dollars
for this useless week and they have
problem after problem after problem
after problem
if you have been screwed by the
timeshare industry you have a story to
tell
about getting locked in one of those
rooms and not being able to get out
until you bought call right now the
phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
have never fallen prey to this and i
have not
but most people that i know have
here is their proposal we have not fed
the tiger here at the zoo
for several days to say that he's greedy
for a meal would be an understatement
however if you will go into the tiger
cage and sit with the tiger for three
hours and pet the tiger who's greedy for
food and is not eaten in three days
we will give you a one year pass to the
zoo for free
and you folks sign up to pet the tiger
in the tiger cage
and you think that this greedy tiger is
not going to eat you
and you sit there and you sit there and
you sit there and you sit there and
you're pressured and you're twisted
and you get hungry and your blood sugar
gets
low many elderly people complain that
they could not get
access to their medicine and the only
way they could get to take their
medication
was to sign up to get out of the room
this is unbelievable unconscionable
over-the-top pressure
from these companies to buy this
this completely useless
product that does nothing but make the
people selling it
rich if you sell timeshares
you are by definition scum stop it go
get a good
job it's awful
you should not do that to people you
should have a conscience
you should look at what you're doing and
think about what the people are gonna
end up with five ten years later
after you sell them that well dave
ramsey you sell people stuff yes i do
and they are better for it ten years
later not worse
there is value in that and i have no con
no no hesitation to do that whatsoever
westgate david siegel is now
86 year old billionaire
86 his wife is 30 years as junior
and was the subject of the famous
documentary
back around 2012 called the queen of
versailles where they began building a
90
000 square foot house we're unable to
finish it
because westgate almost went broke this
one
is one of their timeshare testimonies
online westgate we were scammed into
buying this timeshare only to be told
the most important information
which was in a black binder given to us
was that we had 10 days to cancel we are
out of the 10 day period we cannot use
the time share for one year
every piece of information given to us
was a lie
this is about westgate marriott owning
this timeshare has been such a headache
overall but this covet situation has
really given them an excuse to further
abuse people
i pay my fifteen hundred dollar
maintenance on time by the way can you
rent a hotel room for fifteen hundred
dollars
this is after you paid fourteen thousand
or twenty eight thousand to own the dad
blame thing
pet the tiger baby pet the tiger
nothing is ever available to trade weeks
are lost and now they have to be put
into interval because marriott won't
extend the usage even though
everything was closed due to covet on
top of that
they never even put the points into
interval
says it will now take 12 weeks to press
a button
which means i will lose three months of
usage before it expires
endless hours on the phone and chat only
to hear the same thing over and over
again
you have to wait sorry thank you
marriott you screwed me
and they refused to allow me to speak to
a supervisor or a manager
the worst of the worst is diamond in
2019 we were visiting a diamond resorts
location and were offered a discount
four-day trip
to palm springs if we attended a
timeshare presentation while there
go in the go in the cage pet the tiger
the staff pressured us relentlessly
into making a purchase while at the
presentation we were told that these
resorts
were for the exclusive use of members
that this was a real estate
investment that not traveling more with
our family made us bad parents
finally we felt that we needed to make
the purchase not only to leave but so
that our children could experience the
lifestyle
that this representative was promising
after that day we continued to get
hounded with calls from diamond
employees asking us when we'd be
attending the welcome presentation
every time we tried to book it nothing
was available not only can we not book
rooms
they ripped us off what are we paying
for diamond thank you
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
we're talking about the largest legal
fraud in america today it is legal but
it is an
absolute rip-off it's called a time
share if you've been ripped off by the
purchase of a time share and you want to
tell your story
you can call in right now at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five if you used to work for one
of these companies and you want to tell
the truth about what goes on behind the
scenes
you can call us at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five marty is in phoenix arizona
marty what happened to you hey dave hey
just a quick story uh uh when i was 22
years old my
wife and i were freshly married and she
heard about this timeshare
thing that uh you go there and they give
you away a free barbecue grill or
whatever to listen to their their
presentation so she talked me into going
to it and uh
it was the longest four or five hours of
my life
sitting there listening to this this
pitch that made no sense at all
depending to spend like
i don't know it was like fifteen to
twenty thousand dollars for this time
share
thing that you could use then they
brought up the big hitter
guy that tried to you know really sell
you on it and uh
even at that young age i told the guys
it's just absolutely ridiculous i can
i can stay in a really nice motel for a
lot less money than that
well you've got the option you can trade
go someplace else and such and etc and i
said
well if i want to do that i'll just go
to that place you know
just just give me my stupid barbecue
grill so we can go home
so i told my wife i'm never gonna uh sit
through an experience like that again
that was uh
was that 30 i'm 58 now so how many years
ago was that
36 years ago yeah so that experience
stuck with you did you
actually get the barbecue grill yes we
did it was one of those cheap little
hibachi little
things you know oh so even that was a
rip-off
it was a rip-off yes it was they stole
your five hours
so you you know you you got paid a
dollar an hour you got a five dollar
barbecue grill
and that's for sure and i told my wife
said that you know nothing is free in
this world you know we had to spend five
hours of our time for this chic little
barbecue grill
i said you know it's just uh it to me it
just made no sense i've always
lived by your principles even before i
heard about you
you know to keep you know keep it simple
have no debt we paid off our house in
our 40s
we uh we're your everyday next door
millionaire
uh you know just just i just would
advise people
to buy into nonsense like that you know
if you want to take a vacation
book a nice vacation someplace where you
want to go and
and pay for it but the timeshare thing
is is a total rip-off
yeah yeah i always think i'm kind of
like you that i mean how many
nights how many nights in a hotel room
can you buy for fifteen thousand bucks
exactly all right yeah you get a really
nice motel for that for
i don't know a month or so or a couple
months plus fifteen hundred dollars or
three thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars a year maintenance fees on top
of that
and the special assessments don't forget
those marty thanks for calling in
yeah again guys going to the timeshare
presentation is like going into the
tiger cage the tiger has not eaten for
three days
and you pet the tiger for three hours
and try to not get eaten
so that you get a one year pass to the
zoo don't pet the tiger
just don't do it well i i you know you
and the hilarious thing is you think
you're going to be the exception so you
go down there
and you block yourself in a room with
the tiger
who is greed there's nothing greedier
than a timeshare salesman
except his boss and his boss's boss
people like mike flasky the ceo that
runs diamond
whoo you talk about a character
see they just sold that to hilton
and hilton has just damaged their
wonderful national brand now
because they took on the largest most
grotesque and complained about timeshare
company
in the world called diamond
international and i don't know how much
money mikey got
if you're the ceo i wonder how much
stock and diamond he owned
so how wealthy he became with that
transfer to hilton
you know i wonder if that's public
record james we ought to look that up
that's probably in the sec filings since
we're going to go ahead and continue to
do these exposes on the
interior workings of the timeshare
industry
so any how many of you out there think
about this saw that thing the queen of
versailles
award-winning 2012 american documentary
by filmmaker lauren greenfield with
sundance
so i i watched it and i got to tell you
i watched it because i was p i'm pissed
off the timeshare people
they've been jacking around and i'm
finally just doing something about it
i'm body blowing them right
now and so i watched this and i just
felt sorry for these people they were
just
pitiful people it was hard to be mad at
them because they were just
pitiful just pitiful now david siegel is
the owner of westgate it's now uh
he's now a billionaire again but he
almost lost everything during that
2008 downturn and they were filming this
documentary that came out in 2012. and
get this now siegel and his wife bring
them into the house
and they follow them around with their
dogs pooping in the floor
they've got a whole bunch of kids the
house is an absolute
wreck it's disorganized their spending
habits are
like they're in congress they're
self-absorbed
it's a really sad kind of kind of like
watching those reality shows where the
people on there aren't even real they're
like cartoons
and you just feel sorry for them like if
that was your daughter oh my gosh how
would you feel
if that was your sister how embarrassed
would you be you know
is that's kind of how i felt for him i
felt bad for him except that i sat there
and watched this guy
and the first thing he did was not stop
construction on his 90 000 square foot
house when his company got in trouble he
laid off 7 000 employees
but he didn't give up the 90 000 square
foot house
i it's just principally wrong i think
but what do i know
i'm old-fashioned in 2010 this article
says
uh in january 10th of 2012 the same year
siegel and westgate resorts
filed a lawsuit
in florida against sundance and the
filmmakers of the queen of versailles
claiming
that sundance's published film
description was defamatory
now i will say this it did not leave old
david and his wife looking in a good
light it was not it was not like this
was like a promotional piece for them
which is what i think they thought it
was going to be because of their
uh egos
and so but you let these people in your
house
and followed them around and had no
guidelines on you overseeing the editing
of this
and and they found that your dog's
crapping in the floor your kids stepping
in the dog crap and they put that on
there
and you don't think that and you think
that's defamatory it's not defamatory
what happened
and you allowed them in your house to
film it so the judge threw that out the
arbitrator also wrote that westgate
had failed to show it was damaged from
the documentary finally the arbitrator
wrote that westgate did not remotely
establish the tip the type of malice
required for a defamation claim on
behalf of a public figure
but let me tell you what a 10 billion
dollar industry does
when in doubt they try to sue their
enemies
into submission whether they're right or
not we had an attorney on here last week
when we were talking about this
that said that he
represents 15 different attorneys that
they have run them out of their law
practice these attorneys would
go after the timeshare business to
because their customer to be released
from the timeshare timeshare company
turned around sued
the attorney
and this guy has 15 of these attorneys
that he's representing
as an attorney against the timeshare
business because all they did was try to
run them out of business
so what that's what they do and the
problem is i'm neck deep in cash i don't
have any debt
so guys i'm not going to be that easy
i'm not a little one-man show attorney
law firm i'm not going to be that easy
mikey
you got a problem it's me and you've
pissed me off
by ripping people off so long and then
coming after me
and that was a mistake mikey that was a
mistake
it's going to cost you guys this is just
the beginning of how bad it's going to
hurt
people do not go to a timeshare
presentation
especially if it's westgate diamond
especially if it's marriott
do not go into the tiger cage and pet
the tiger
don't do it you're going to get bitten
now if you have had a time share
experience and you want to share it this
is your time we're going to do that in
the next segment
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two two five hilton grand vacations is
entered into a definitive agreement to
acquire diamond resorts international
the largest independent timeshare
operator in a stock-based transaction
value
1.4 billion dollars
[Music]
all on the back of people that went into
the tiger cage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in 2017 arizona attorney general mark
fernbernovich announced
that diamond resorts corporation has
agreed to settle for eight hundred
thousand dollars in a case involving
allegations of customer deception
diamond resorts is a timeshare sales
company with resorts in the united
states and international locations
according
to the attorney general's office the
company used deceptive sales practices
no it's not possible
during sales presentations the company
allegedly made oral misrepresentations
and false statements
no couldn't happen
attorney general argued that diamond
resorts has made misrepresentations
about annual maintenance fee increases
of course membership resale there's no
such thing
and buyback programs they don't happen
timeshare membership
resale markets don't exist the ability
to rent time share vacations and
discounts on other travel needs
can't get it done their office charge
time and resorts with violating the
arizona consumer fraud act
as per the settlement agreement diamond
will need to make changes
to its business practices the settlement
also
includes the creation of a
relinquishment program
wherein consumers can return their
timeshares if they want to and have no
further obligations
good luck with that one good luck with
that one just call up oh mikey and say
mikey i want out of my time shirt
diamond
you know what he'll say
yeah brandon is with us brandon is in
phoenix arizona hey brandon what
happened
hey how's it going dude i'm having way
too much fun what's up
i hear that so i'm 28 years old and my
wife is
just turning 30 this month but about two
years ago
on her birthday or maybe it was the year
that we got married
um we had gone down to sedona arizona
for her birthday and there was a nice
gentleman
on the streets offering a 50 stick gift
card and we were
you know kind of tight being newlyweds
on money and so that gift card sounded
nice to take her out for her birthday
and then on top of that um we had to go
sit through
about an hour to an hour and a half
presentation as he put it
on a diamond resort timeshare
and he said at the end of it we get a
week-long vacation that we get to choose
from between
uh about five packages so it sounded
good we went to the uh
the tigers then as you put it and we
actually we made it out alive it's a
success story but
when we got there it ended up being
about three to
four and a half hours if i remember
correctly and then after i got through
the sales person she brought in her boss
and after i got through her boss
we had to wait around for about 30 to 40
minutes more and go sit through the
final
boss guy and we finally left with our
vacation package but the funny thing is
to this day we still haven't had time to
use it let alone spend twenty to fifty
thousand dollars on a timeshare
that we would probably never spend that
much in our lifetime vacationing
yeah you know amen and if you did you
could go to some really nice place
even the free stuff isn't worth it you
know i mean all that free stuff isn't
worth
you know what you have to go through to
to listen to these people
yeah and they're they're convincing i
actually just uh was that we were in
cabo
over uh christmas and i was playing golf
and i were playing golf with this really
nice place
i thought and uh when i finish up the
little guy comes over to me hey how'd
you do that
i thought he's getting my bags and stuff
and he starts telling me he goes uh
hey hey man did you pay for your golf
and i went well sure of course i did
he goes well you didn't have to and i
went really why and he goes i'll pay for
it for you and i went oh really why
and he goes well we do that and and then
about you know i start to realize it
just starts to dawn on me this is an
invitation to the tiger cage
all for a round of golf and so i just
said no honey it's okay
it's okay he was going to refund me for
my green fees which were really
yeah that would have been a real bad use
of my time elizabeth's in boise idaho
hey elizabeth tell us about your
timeshare experience
hello hi dave um dave i we're actually
triple losers
and you know we're not going to go back
for more but our first one was at the
marriott newport coast in newport beach
california
and they put us in this we were supposed
to be able to stay there right
and have the sales pitch we have the
sales pitch and everything but they
didn't have any place for us to stay
so they put us in this real dumpy hotel
okay so that didn't go over so we left
that
yeah um
in palm desert and we bought it we
bought a one bedroom
darling place and we loved it we got the
we got our
to play golf and everything and then
they got rid of the one bedroom
so they virtually pushed us out to where
we would have to have been
they sold you a one bedroom and then
they got rid of the one bedroom so they
couldn't provide to you what they sold
you
correct correct and their answer to that
was not to give you a refund of course
well after many months and a lot of
arguments and a lot of pushing and
threatening
we finally got a refund because he
virtually sold us a contract that no
longer existed
yeah i would think i mean that would be
straight up that would be
that wouldn't be legalized fraud that'd
be just like fraud okay so
uh which company was that one
that was bermuda dunes and i don't know
if it's its own
entity i can't remember okay at this
time but uh
that wasn't say it again it was called
what
bermuda dunes bermuda dunes okay
beware of the one bedrooms because they
don't have them okay
yes yeah so that just disappeared okay
but that was a lot of fighting and a lot
of stress
our third one as we as if we weren't the
biggest suckers in the world
was diamond in sedona as your previous
caller just identified so diamond and
sedona
puts you through the ringer three or
four hours you're listening and they'll
give you
a a little bit of food and maybe some
oranges to keep your glucose going in
your blood
and then they don't really want you to
go to the bathroom and they
don't want you to leave to go eat and so
i know i'm like okay so i can't i can't
even hardly urinate here so
we stayed there and went through that
and then
they put us in the dumpiest place i've
ever seen
for the night and i'm like this is
unbelievable
after you sat through all that
believable after we sat through all that
we stayed one night and then i called
him back i called the show and thingy
whatever people and i said
this is ridiculous and she said okay
we've got another place for you
it was worse than the first one oh my
gosh but you didn't buy there so that
was
oh i'll never buy a time share
or visit one of these crooks again
okay i love it you're awesome
thank you thank you so so much randy is
in
i'm sorry glenn is in jackson tennessee
hey glenn tell us your time share story
hey dave hey it was uh 2005.
my wife and i were on our honeymoon in
gatlinburg we were approached by
a young woman in a gas station parking
lot
offered the cash prize to come sit
through
through the spill yeah because i
generally get really good things by
people who approach me in a gas station
parking lot
[Laughter]
they're at uh you know they're they pop
up like weeds everywhere they're
somewhere
but uh we we were convinced to buy a
vacation package
and we upgraded from that the year we
took our vacation
and we actually used our times here uh
for every other year for six years uh
it's
at the great smoky mountains this was
westgate resort
and um and then similar to your last
caller
um the unit that we were
were using each uh every other year was
going to go away
and so basically we were basically flat
out told we would own something that
wasn't worth quote unquote
owned something that we couldn't use um
you know as they define ownership and so
we sat through hours of trying to decide
what to do at a different
uh well it was the west gate but a
different result they can
resort rather and they convinced us to
upgrade
some stories of being able to sell later
or rent later and so
um it was actually god's saying that
we found out about timeshare exit team
from your program
and uh worked with them and had a
successful exit
oh they got you out it's probably they
did very good
ago this was finished and in the time
since
uh they've gone through obviously
they've been successful because
timeshare companies have come against
them hard yeah uh
and it was our it was my distinct
pleasure actually to speak on their
behalf and say hey
we were the ones swindled by timeshare
companies
not not time sharing exciting yeah well
we'll come back and talk about that a
little bit
that'd be a good thing to let everybody
know about this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 18 15
the heart of discerning acquires
knowledge for the ears of the wise
seek it out albert einstein says it's
not that i'm so smart
it's just that i stay with problems
longer
you see that's me i'm not that smart i
just stay with it
like this whole time share thing i'm
staying with it so i'm gonna keep
talking about you guys
so here's the deal so one of the
problems i had here on the radio was
that people needed to
find inexpensive term insurance so we
went and found
zander insurance and endorsed them and
they've helped a whole lot of people
with their term insurance
people also needed help with their real
estate and we went and found real estate
agents and we call them endorsed local
providers
that we endorse all over america some of
the top insurance some of the top
real estate agents and their endorsed
local providers and so on
and so one of the things we did we've
done over the 30 years of being on the
air is when we find a problem that you
guys have
we don't necessarily need to get in
those businesses
we just help someone that's already in
those businesses help you
if they're reputable and they have the
solution to your problem but i was
getting all these calls for
20 years dave i can't get out of my
timeshare i can't sell it i can't get
them to
call them i can't talk them into it i've
offered to pay them to take it back they
won't
i've offered to sell it i've offered i
can't get i can't donate it to charity i
can't get rid of it i'm stuck
so these two young guys call us and they
started a
timeshare exit company called timeshare
exit team
and it was on a couple of radio stations
it was doing pretty well around america
and they said they won't be on the dave
ramsey show and i go
guys when i put you on here and i say
you can get people out of time shares
your business is going to explode
exponentially well that's what we want i
said yeah but can you handle
all those phone calls can you handle all
those cases can you get all this work
done
because you know you can't take all this
business on and not take care of these
people
well i was wrong it didn't explode it
exploded
i mean it was amazing and these poor
guys they they were
they they were getting people out of
town sharers left and right left and
right left and right left and right but
they couldn't hire fast enough they
couldn't keep
up with the phone calls they couldn't
keep up and every time we would get
complaints because somebody wouldn't get
their phone call returned or something
we get on them
and they say i know we're hiring and
we're doing this and we even sent them
some of our leadership training
so they could grow their businesses so
that they could get the job done
to get you people out of your timeshares
they got over twenty thousand people out
of timeshares
and they were one of the most successful
timeshare comp exit companies in america
they weren't the first they weren't even
probably the best but they were very
successful
uh we sent them a lot of volume
obviously uh
but they grew they outgrew their ability
to return phone calls and get everything
done
they ended up just they got overwhelmed
because it was so stinking popular
because people
hate time shares so the timeshare
companies
decide to target them and start suing
them
and banding together and suing them and
mike flasky got up and stood in front of
the timeshare association
word is i haven't found the actual
transcript yet but we've heard from
bloggers in the industry
that he stood up and said he's going to
pledge that the industry is pledging 50
million dollars to put
anybody in the timeshare exit business
out of business that they were going to
sue them until they ran them out of
business
and so they started suing timeshare exit
team over and over and over and over
again
then they talk the uh uh attorney
general over in washington state into
going after them
i've yet to figure out how that happens
a little more to come on that later i
promise you i'm just still investigating
that
uh and he's trying to depose me which is
funny
uh and man i mean this has been a these
companies are trying to
depose me because i endorsed them of
course i endorsed them
they got 20 000 people other time shares
but they've now been overwhelmed with
legal fees
and so they're no longer on the air with
us because they're spending all of their
money
trying to stay alive in these legal
battles
and so now i don't know i can't figure
out how the timeshare business
they have so much money they just buy
their way into everything or intimidate
their way into everything
apparently because then inside edition
which is a
well-known what piece of crap tabloid
thing right uh decides they're gonna do
a thing on timeshare exit team
and they're gonna do a thing on me
because i endorse them but timeshare
exit teams ripping people off you got it
wrong inside edition
timeshare exit team isn't who's ripping
people off it's the timeshare companies
that are ripping people off
so poor little poor little dumb lisa
guerrero
with uh inside edition decides she's
going to do a story so she calls us and
of course we ignore her because they're
doing a hit piece and you don't
participate in your own headpiece it's a
ruling
media and i'm a public figure so why am
i going to give you information to do a
hit piece on me that's just dumb i'm not
so just
jump in the creek besides that you're
inside addition you're a tabloid
and little lisa guerrero i mean
everybody kind of knows about her she's
kind of a laughingstock she was on
monday night football for a whole year
uh this is back in the 2000's abc sports
dismissed lisa guerrero from her job as
sideline reporter
on monday night football a position she
held for just one season she came to abc
from fox sports with limited
sports broadcasting experience yeah you
think she'll be replaced by michelle
tuffola
and a lead sideline reporter for abc and
espn her freshman season on monday night
football was filled with awkward moments
and competence mistakes and most notably
after the reagan's regular
season opening between the jets and the
washington redskins a
stumbled interview with patrick ramsey
she could not improve she was
incompetent dumb
and they fired her off monday night
football so now she's a star reporter on
inside edition
so she attacks me in the lobby
a week and a half ago of the omni in
dallas while we're there doing our
entree leadership event ambushes you
know one of these ambush things where
they pop
out with the microphone start running
along trying to get the comment and all
this stuff
and i'm walking with one of my team
members along and uh
he steps between us and
she is whacking him with her arm
trying to push him out of the way to get
to me
and now she goes on instagram and says
we attacked her and her arm is bruised
so lisa we have the omni security
footage
and we've broken it down frame by frame
and sweet girl here's how it works you
will not hurt your arm if you don't hit
people with it
you were not attacked you were the
attacker
and any of you that have seen the
bruises on her forearm these are the
bruises of
someone that is aggressively attacking
someone not someone who is
being attacked you don't get a bruise
across the whole front of your forearm
when you're attacked
that's when you're hitting someone that
that happens
and you go on national television and
say dave ramsey's goons beat you up
you poor stupid little girl i think
maybe the way you hurt your arm is when
you got in bed with the timeshare people
that might have been when you hurt your
arm
that's very possible something for you
guys to think about out there
so this is how this stuff works i hear
when you deal with these multi-billion
dollar
companies multi-billion dollar companies
will put failed sideline reporters from
inside edition on you
and on time share exit team and put dave
ramsey up as if he somehow endorsed
somebody he shouldn't have endorsed
was timeshare exit team perfect
absolutely not
absolutely not they took on too much
business
they couldn't return everybody's phone
calls they did not do a stellar job
and we talked to them about it several
times we were trying to work with them
and trying to work their way through it
but basically they have been hammered
now
by legal fees and they can no longer you
know afford to be on the dave ramsey
show to provide the service
to get you people out of a timeshare
because they're spending all of their
bandwidth
fighting with these bozos
people like david siegel
and you know the princess of versailles
right oh my god or mikey flasky who just
got i don't know how much money from
this hilton sale
diamond bought by hilton hilton you have
a real problem
you've just damaged your brand you took
on one of the most grotesque
brands in all of timeshare one of the
most horrendous
group of people lack of character
anywhere
and you made them part of hilton you
guys
really just screwed up and you gave them
1.4 billion dollars
and they screw people left and right
every day
there's comments all over the internet
they the
attorney general shuts them down gets an
800
000 fine against them
in the city in the state of arizona and
we just heard
several diamond testimonies here on the
air from people who tried to deal with
diamond or got screwed by diamond
or any of these other things so this is
how this works you guys
so here's the thing
not many people get the opportunity to
hit back on
pieces of crap in the press when they do
a bad job
i happen to have a platform that allows
me to tell you people what really
happened
and what the real truth is so inside
edition in case you didn't figure it out
you suck that puts
the dave ramsey show in the books this
hour
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
you